now to another murder case another
disturbing case overall this one in
Massachusetts where Brian Walsh has
pleaded not guilty to murdering his wife
Anna this was in court yesterday she was
last seen early on January 1st New
Year's Day afterwards though prosecutors
say that Walsh searched online
repeatedly in fact for tips on how to
dispose of a body also clean up blood
Nancy Chen reports from outside the
courthouse in Quincy Massachusetts
in court Brian Walsh stood motionless as
prosecutors alleged he killed his wife
and disposed of the 39 year old's body
after she disappeared on New Year's Day
rather than divorce it was pleased that
Ryan Walsh this moment on Walsh who
discarded her body police say Walsh told
investigators he last saw the mother of
three early January 1st as she was about
to take a car to the airport the
prosecutors say there is no record of
that ride Anna was reported missing by
her employer three days later on
Wednesday prosecutors said Walsh
searched a series of disturbing
questions on his son's iPad starting
just hours after Anna was last seen by a
friend at 4 58 a.m how to stop a body
from decomposing at 5 20 am he searched
how to found the body the next day
prosecutors say Walsh about 450 dollars
worth of supplies in including cleaning
materials they say investigators also
discovered blood and knives in the
couple's basement and found video of a
man resembling Walsh lugging a heavy bag
and discarding items in several
dumpsters prosecutors say some bags have
already been incinerated but police
found other bags containing a hatchet
hacksaw towels honest covid-19 vaccine
card and items she was last seen wearing
was being alleged is horrifying Pamela
Barty was a friend of honest the truth
needs to be told because I think that
not knowing is much more painful
Anna Walsh's body has not been found
Brian Walsh pleaded not guilty and is
being held without bail in a statement
his attorney doubted the strength of the
case adding she quote intends to win his
next court appearance is February 9th
Gail
yeah Nancy keeps thinking about Anna's
very young children her family and
friends thank you so much